most video games take themselves pretty
seriously sure sometimes a game like
Octodad or salmon max lifts through the
cracks but by and large most games these
days seem to be a grim litany of
post-apocalyptic despair which is why
inside jokes are so important as they
often provide a bit of much-needed
levity the only problem with inside
jokes learning how to recognize them
here's a look at some inside jokes only
real gamers will understand and your
guide to finally catching the gags you
missed the first time around
zombie genocide er you and your friends
have probably competed to see who can
kill the most virtual zombies the set
probably pales in comparison to the
rivalry between the competing zombie
titles Dead Rising and left for dead see
in Dead Rising there's an achievement
called zombie genocide er that players
can earn by killing fifty three thousand
five hundred ninety four zombies the
entire population of the city the game
is based in well left4dead decided to
literally one-up that by putting in
their own achievement to kill fifty 3595
zombies naturally Dead Rising 2
responded with a new achievement
requiring fifty two thousand five
hundred ninety six kills while Dead
Rising free laughed at their own jokes
by raising the total to said two
thousand five hundred and ninety-seven
well it's good to have goals anyway
whimsy Shire when Blizzard announced
Diablo 3 some fans were furious because
the game's color scheme looks too bright
which sadly is just the kind of thing
that gamers typically get worked up
about
in response Blizzard not only didn't
change the color scheme they responded
to the controversy by adding a neon
Technicolor zone called whimsy Shire
filled with rainbows unicorns teddy
bears and happy clouds best of all
getting to whimsy Shire was extremely
complex and difficult meaning all those
super hardcore fans who complained about
the game's color scheme had to work
extra hard to find it and you thought
boljan was Wizards best troll Dan Hibiki
one video game developer SNK released
art of fighting back in 1992 players
couldn't help but notice that the main
character Ryo seems to be a direct
ripoff of the popular Street Fighter
character Ryu Capcom
maker of Street Fighter notice - they
decided to get their revenge by adding a
secret character to their games called
Dan Hibiki who was a parody of
and who totally sucks in every possible
way [ __ ] you Mike yeah ironically while
art of fighting and real have become
almost completely forgotten by the
fighting game world Dan Hibiki has
survived and has even become a cult
favorite among hardcore gamers beating
your opponent with a perpetually
overmatched Dan is considered a badge of
honour daddy's back every now and then
Grand Theft Auto 5 main character
Michael will randomly shout an unusual
catchphrase daddy's back biches it's in
character for Michael to say something
like that but it's also designed to
drive a specific group of players crazy
that's because it's the first line from
the first mission in Grand Theft Auto
for a game that's lived on for years in
the modding community but most mods
don't allow you to save the game so
every time you play you have to start
over from the beginning and here this
line again and again and again again and
again and again and again and again
making one of the lead characters of
Grand Theft Auto 5 randomly say it is
just rubbing salt in the wound the
dopefish the classic computer game
Commander Keen describes the dull fish
like this the second dumbest creature in
the universe
this creature thought patterns go swim
swim hungry win swim hungry aside from
his bulging eyes buck tooth grin and
ability to fart on command
there is nothing particularly special
about the dopefish despite this though
he's become a game designer meme
appearing in wacky wheels quakes 1 2 & 3
descent 3 Max Payne hitman 2 and many
many more just when you thought it was
safe to go back in the water
Gilgamesh from chocobos to CID the Final
Fantasy series has many recurring
creatures and characters but there is
only one who has an in story reason for
popping up again and again
while most Final Fantasy games don't
connect to each other directly in Final
Fantasy 5
Gilgamesh is trapped in a void outside
of space and time leaving him free to
show up as a fourth wall breaking Easter
egg in almost every Final Fantasy game
that's followed
and I'd be stuck in digital in Rome
Saints Row 4 is voice options one of the
best things about the Saints Row games
is a series detailed and flexible
character creation tool which allows you
to make some truly bizarre protagonists
and that level of customization extends
to the voice option too you can give
your saints row 4 protagonist one of
seven voices including one called simply
nolan north my fellow Americans I know a
lot of people have concerns about this
sunday sunday sunday but i urge everyone
to remember awesome monster trucks out
nolan north of course has provided the
voices for seemingly every character in
videogames ranging from uncharted and
assassin's creed all the way to the last
of us and destiny to name just a few
including him as his own specific option
is pretty funny and a great nod to one
of the most popular and totally
overexposed voices and gaming the cuoco
revenge squad it started as a joke in
the Legend of Zelda a link to the past
but the cuca revenge squad which is a
group of angry chickens that descend
from the skies to kill you if you harass
one of their feathered brethren has
spread like a poultry plague across the
gaming landscape beyond appearing in
several Zelda games the revenge squad
has also popped up in everything from
Super Smash Brothers to Guild Wars 2 and
even got a shout-out in hearthstone in
short if you see a chicken in a video
game it's probably best to leave it
alone you know just in case thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
you